yeah welcome to this video playing sv
mihaylov from Norway it's going for a
six low Kelly variation not a lot such a
bad line we get you a regular Sicilian a
rather positional strategical line with
them g 30 then sold this way is trying
to make sure that I don't get don't get
a bishop on b6 so we should be 394
interesting ok let's this is some part
of the normal
normal set of plans here so how to
continue yeah 92 it just takes a 5 mm
yeah I don't like that too much maybe a4
a5 Watson awesome i mistimed idea
yeah covering btooom yeah I don't have I
don't have a plane here really a problem
how to how to proceed in this position
this is a absolutely annoying piece on
c4 I move move the bishop he might take
on me to hope he just decided that the
bishop Aires is worth giving this this
great night away for I'm not so sure I'm
obviously a big fan of the bishops but
still this night was really nuisance
yeah not sure what the rook is doing on
our own a two so how to continue is this
night efore b6 an idea yeah black black
is very comfortable here there's no
doubt about that you can also just play
d 5 this is just them yeah just a fine
position oh and he's even trying to to
play a really really sophisticated here
just recapturing what's good as well
okay if I take a my busted on the D file
and maybe yeah but if I don't take I'm
completely completely tied up
I don't see how he actually wins apiece
now checking e6 maybe this was a bit a
bit too much p 7 is also hanging yeah i
think this he misplayed that with simple
muslim he could have gotten a great
position and now with this complicated
player his and his his some in the in
some trouble
yeah is this playable
i won
continued phone somehow this looks like
it's there's a technical problem with
that not really sure
somehow this doesn't look right for
black I'm not touch show with with if if
if this Queenie five is really good
who you know should takes rook jigs hmm
ok 50 seconds hmm
yeah this was most likely not the best
anyway takes 90s he can just takes it
too
yeah this was my idea
which isn't exactly great I'm hoping
that he's trying to avoid the repetition
still fighting for a win here despite
the time
he takes had the beep are should count
for something this Bishop on f7 is just
an enormously bad piece
ideas rook c6 and check the a pond
on this one
yeah okay I must move matter of time
check time Jane
who have seven minutes the idea yes
checkmate okay yeah another tricky and
there SAT for well yeah yeah this kind
of positioners is is better for why but
I didn't really have any time to to
figure this out yeah Bishop c4 it's a
good move for example if you have a bit
of time you can see them and this rook
b8 a strong attending night c 8 hmm yeah
okay and so this was wasn't the best but
check check
yeah the immediate f4 would threaten
made also and now he five is a draw you
five him and no maid she causes was it
was a neat trick but okay it probably
should should should have ended in a
draw um it was really a bad position
here this is really bad probably yeah
this is a mistake allowing that and I
should play who I don't know what but
something else maybe have for even the
night on c4 is just terrible for for me
hmm interesting alright thanks for
watching